welcome to this video playing hmm Cesc a
la ropa or something from Spain until we
get a cara con pollo yeah this funny 94
line which i have played a couple of
times now with the quite quite good
results 24 f6 Queenie fork will be
successor the usual way to to play that
push up to d2 yeah interesting just down
just a sec song it's not should I should
I protect the pawn bishop a fiver
certainly a playable move yeah why not
actually he cannot go nighty too because
of 93 and so at least i hope that 93 s
good on 92 92 to g3 otherwise would be a
rather good idea night h3 i can just
take and play 9 a-3 checkup zone he has
got some development problems the spawn
only for us really it's really a
nuisance so e 6 or something else yeah
when he should be good opening up the
position when you're being a slightly
better developed yeah he can do without
him and but he cannot play Bishop g2 so
I didn't think that this is much of a
problem why what what can give this
check now what is the big point of the
bishop moves ok answer go ahead yeah
people really have problems with the
slide seen some some really weird really
weird ways to to play this knight c6
maybe isn't this just very strong
where's the Queen going and they take on
d5 next move it's got the King on d1
yeah just takes d5 next move and resins
actually Queen only can go to e3y resins
get another very quick win for this line
yeah it's it's difficult it's difficult
to handle what needs to take here on you
for my queen bee 62 leads to yeah a mess
this is already looking rather rather
comfortable but maybe maybe f4 or
something this already looks shaky on
computers on minus 2 minus 2 this is
amazing
yeah this is winning already now yeah
well you need to develop at one point
Bishop g5 to d2 back to f4 a tree and g4
quite weird but somehow people are very
irritated by this by this line yeah
thanks for watching